in 2007 this all started correct
and
i don't know when the trolling saga
started but it felt like it lasted a
millennia so
what's the trolling saga i feel like
there was like 30 episodes where it was
just trolling i mean yeah there was so
there's 30 episodes was like
in the span of two years
yeah
it's the problem is is that there is i
feel like uh the recent history of uh
christine has been very
not well not normal i think he meant to
say cristory for the christophery
terminology there's not as much
essentially right i feel like there was
a lot more recordings of trolling and
stuff and just the amount of it
there's a lot still but it's mostly
confined to
to long twitter rants and like threads
on twitter and not not that many videos
which i guess is not not as entertaining
to most people so what kind of trolling
are we talking about here oh there's
some egregious stuff do you wanna oh
sure um things really started to kick
off in around 2008 i guess when trolls
decided to pretend pretend to be
uh females online interested in chris
right yes
of course and that happened many times
actually
uh chris kept falling for it every time
which is unfortunate every single time
every single time yeah so you think like
even you know
it's like how many times they weren't
exactly 10th catfish
it's like how many catfishes before
you're like i've seen this one before
this looks awfully familiar you know one
thing as well that is really concerning
about uh you know christian out this
whole documentary especially in the
earlier years is just
how much chris wants to have sex
yeah i like that yeah because i think
that's like the only way that you could
fall for catfish that many times right
they're like very uncomfortable just
once a girl yeah how did he refer to
girls at that point because i remember a
boyfriend-free girl oh boyfriend free
girl
[Laughter]
we need like an entire encyclopedia this
is like this podcast will not do it
justice hopefully what we can do is give
you a basic introduction and a quick
rundown of the important events and that
if you really enjoy
or you are extremely intrigued by what
you hear you can go and watch gino's
videos about yeah yeah but we'll talk
about it and yeah boyfriend free girl is
yeah one of my favorite phrases of all
time by the way that's uh that's
officially called a quick ism
so these are all words that are used by
chris yeah invented by chris kind of
yeah
it's like it sounds like a story like a
story you know the the thing that's very
concerning about uh christian the whole
thing especially earlier on is the way
that he talks about sex is very much uh
almost like a
watching a caveman speak about sex right
yeah where it's like i need i want sex
it's just like there's no emotion
you know there's no mention of wanting
to be close with someone it's just i
just want to have sex it's advice
i want to make love it's more like i
just want to procreate yeah like vibe
right yeah it's really strange um and i
think that's that also starts like you
said it starts trolling saga which has
some really disgusting points right
which i mean so they start trolling with
the catfishing and then then it goes
we're not at the discussing point yet oh
no well it depends what
it depends what flavor of because you
know i feel like there's a little bit
for everyone in terms of disgusting
um what is this an idea
just a little something for everyone
whichever thing disgusts you the most
at some point chris has been involved
with it yeah like whichever thing
whichever thing disgusts you whether it
be um
i think one thing that i think was the
first thing that happened that really
caught me off guard and i i knew that
this documentary was not going in good
places
um i can't remember if this was the
first or what
there is
many of the trolls i think you correct
me if i'm wrong here they often when
they were pretending to be boyfriend and
uh girlfriend they would like convince
chris that they were like almost dating
right right right and then they would
ask chris for videos
of him doing certain things at the time
videos and pictures yes close-up
pictures of certain body parts yes
um yeah
and i i just remember i was taking a
bath one time watching this documentary
i was just like cleaning you know just
chilling you know because you know you
have a nice path in japan that's really
and i remember it was like and then
chris uh bought the cake and then filmed
himself sitting on it and i was like
what
what so
you proceeded to scrub harder
i'm not clean enough i'm not clean
enough so what so what was why did this
all happen i think it's just a way to
see you know
would chris actually do this
just just to challenge chris in a way as
well
and um
i guess this also comes as a as a
consequence to the state of the internet
at that time where where it could be
anonymous a lot more easily yeah it was
very open yeah kind of just sounds like
there were limit testing well it was
like that that year was like the wild
west as well where everyone came in
mid 2000's internet was terrifying yeah
that was oh my god yeah i remember
2000's internet man
it was literally like the lawless place
yeah like because i think at the time i
was on i was mostly on new grounds at
the time yeah that place was truly like
you know if it was the wild west there
would be duels happening left and right
people getting shot down yeah and this
was for two years mainly the main mostly
two years and was this because
chris was just extremely active in
responding it was because
there was just a lot more of it like a
lot more trolls than there is now
there's what was the reason why there
was just so much in those two years do
you think
well it helps that chris provided many
entertaining videos
so i kind of created content for them to
laugh at um there was this uh certain
group a very close-knit group called
the private villa of corrupted citizens
like i don't even know if you're making
you know
a lot of the trolls sometimes just seem
as pathetic as chris sometimes yeah yeah
you know i'm watching this you're like i
don't know who's more pathetic the guy
trying to get chris rubbing a
cake in his ass video or chris yeah you
can't i can't decide how you feel when
i'm like talking about faye yeah yeah
yeah yeah
this is this is as difficult as fate to
get into i think this is the chris
laura's
i think chris law is in his own world
yeah definitely so this trolling group
uh the pvcc which is actually named
after
a thing in sonichu
the comic series so chris made this name
up it wasn't the trolls um the pvcc was
also the name of their uh community
college
or the piedmont virginia community
college renamed as the private villa of
corrupted citizens because because to
chris that college um symbolized a very
dark time in their history because
because the dean
of of the school prevented chris from
from posting uh an attraction sign on
the wall asking or looking for a
girlfriend chris would often post signs
across the school and then also around
their area yeah just advertising that
they wanted a boyfriend-free girl
right yes wow it's very strange because
i think the lack of awareness is just
always the achilles heel
came to chris yeah and uh i believe for
example there was a period where chris
got kicked out of the mall
at least once yeah for putting up signs
well it wasn't signs it was it was
loitering uh
um yes they would as well and also maybe
throw throw a rock with the red string
attached
and try to like
lure
her girl
you're making this sound
it's called the red string of fates
oh right that's popular in uh japanese
culture yeah
so chris was literally fishing for girls
that was at least one one attempt at
that yeah okay and then uh
yeah chris was actually um very
infamously dog piled on by by security
guards and uh thrown in jail i guess for
for a little bit but then released and
then permanently or like temporarily
banned from the mall right the local
mall so yeah
that was an issue for chris because that
prevented chris from
from um
going to the go-to hotspot for
boyfriend-free girls
i can't ever take it seriously when you
say that
so what i find fascinating right is that
from like from an outsider looking in
you do kind of you want to feel
sympathetic towards this person right
because they are getting the worst of
online trolls right but at some point
you just you just hear a story about
something that they do and you're just
like what what is wrong with you like it
very much pushes the limit of
you know how much accountability
you put on someone yes uh especially
when chris does have like quite severe
autism yeah it's very difficult to feel
like
man if this was a normal person this
would be totally your fault but also how
much can you you know like i said
earlier there's so much factors of like
you can clearly tell the upbringing yeah
was uh questionable maybe
i don't know how good the parenting was
i mean i'm not a parent i can't judge
right
but you you have to have learned some of
these things from somewhere right
i mean what what for you was like the
sympathy line that like chris like went
over the line and just like nope like
there's no way i can root for you
anymore if they're if they're well where
are you at the sympathy line i mean
i'm not personally i'm not very
sympathetic now yeah but um especially
not after the recent events
recently now it's like there's no
sympathy there
there's like all sympathy is gone yeah
the sympathy line is just like in the in
like the dust at this point but yeah
like i said remember i was watching it
and and there was parts where like i
genuinely felt like sympathetic towards
chris yeah i wanted to see chris do
better and then there was just a rant
about why chris hated gay people at some
point and i was like for [ __ ] sake
but was that orchestrated by the trolls
no no that was i believe a lot of them a
lot of the issues of
of upbringing with chris is the parents
who were very old when chris was
conceived uh the father was 54 the
mother was 40. so they were already
old-timey kind of people who didn't
really understand what autism was when
yeah right was diagnosed with it and
they were kind of afraid of um of
letting chris go to a to a special
school for autism or you know to treat
it in any way and just they kind of
pretended that it didn't exist and kind
of tried it right yeah